la peur fait partie du quotidien des
mois qu'on contacté Radio-Canada pour
dénoncer la zone de non-droits qui est
devenue la petite communauté il parle de
coup de feu incessant de conduite
dangereuse de l'emprise du crime
organisé il se sentent complètement
abandonnés imaginez
personne ne vous écoute
l'enfer que la situation que nous sommes
trouvés à ce moment c'est à cause de la
gouvernement beaucoup de gens se sentent
pas en sécurité dans leur communauté il
y a des conditions qui seraient
comparables entièrement
la gouvernance la politique les enjeux
sociaux ce qui crée un climat dans notre
communauté qui est propice à
l'instauration du crime organisé face à
cette situation autant le fédéral que le
provincial marche sur des œufs la Sûreté
du Québec
regarde comment elle peut intervenir
donc il faut intervenir maintenant faut
le faire en collaboration avec les
communautés autochtone la SQ affirmagir
mais peut-être pas à la vitesse qu'elle
voudrait elle attend une demande d'aide
claire et directe de la part du Conseil
de bande qui lui hésite sur les moyens à
prendre pour rétablir l'ordre de son
côté
Ottawa refuse d'intervenir pour contenir
les déversements toxiques du dépotoir
illégal tant que le conseil de bande n'a
pas retiré les droits fonciers des
frères Gabriel propriétaire de ces
terres sans oublier que la gouvernance
du Conseil de banque est remise en
question au sein même de la communauté
la pression est forte ce n'est pas
responsable
la part des gouvernements de demander au
Conseil de banque à la situation qu'ils
vivent en ce moment de prendre position
le maire d'auca craint que les
événements de 2004 se reproduisent en
janvier cette année-là le poste de
police de ganas attaqué est vantalisé et
la maison du grand chef James Gabriel
incendié à la suite d'une opération
policière ratée contre le crime organisé
est-ce que la solution policières c'est
la solution
au problème qui se passait dans notre
communauté moi je suis David non est-ce
que ça peut être un outil
potentiellement c'est certain mais il
faut vraiment investir sérieusement dans
la restauration de la santé sociale de
notre communauté une rencontre entre
Ottawa Québec et le grand chef Victor
bon Spiel
est présenté au Canada Montréal